hey guys it is Tuesday welcome to the
counts of news alter the couch of gaming
and the cats are taking naps at work my
name is Jess here's the latest Destiny's
Halloween themed event festival of the
Lost kicked off today and it's letting
you fulfill all your Harry Potter
fantasies well at least some of them
like last year the event lets you trick
or treat around the tower to receive
candy from most NPCs and raisins from
eris morn the social spaces have all
been decorated for the occasion and some
of the characters you encounter are
wearing masks a number of players
including reddit user nomnom zombie 17
very appropriate have uncovered a
special Sparrow called the lost room
down by the amote kiosk in the lounge
it's hidden atop some shelves so jump if
you can't spot it immediately the broom
does expire at the end of festival of
the Lost but until then you can zoom
around on it to your heart's content the
Rosens from eros also now actually do
something you can take them to the
speaker to trade them in along with 25
motes of light for ascendant raisins a
series of trades then follows which
culminates in you getting a sweet new
black shader and a piece of celery I
think I can guess which you're more
excited for first of all the left ends
on november eighth next up the division
just received a massive patch which is
great for those of you still playing the
Division II bees up said they would be
delaying the game's final 2 DLC packs to
focus on improving the overall game
experience with the 1.4 update the
update comes in at around five gigabytes
depending on your platform and is
focused on bug fixes making loot drops
more relevant and balancing gear sets
and weapons the patch also aims to
improve the solo play experience the
updates being released in response to
fan feedback and to fix lingering issues
if for some reason you haven't picked
this one up yet and now want to amazon
has the division discounted to under 18
bucks on all platforms finally Xbox boss
Phil Spencer is posted about the
progress of Xbox Scorpio on Twitter
Spencer told an inquiring fan i'm in a
day long review
of where the team is on Scorpio right
now amazing progress and we are feeling
good about schedule the more powerful
version of the xbox one is slated to
arrive next holiday season earlier this
month Spencer told GameSpot they're a
little ahead of schedule on their
Hardware timeline the console has been
described as premium so it's unlikely to
be cheap but Microsoft are also calling
it the most powerful console ever made
so hopefully it stacks up to the price
tag do let me know your thoughts on
today's stories head to gamespot for
news on Quint and Skyrim and I will you
again tomorrow